Good morning, Hank, it's Tuesday.
So, dishonesty has a storied place in american politics,
but for the past several decades maybe our most prominent form of deception
has been the so-called non-denial denial. I first heard that term while reading
'All the President's Men',
about the Watergate cover-up that led to
President Richard Nixon's resignation
back in 1974. Like Nixon's press
secretary Ronald Ziegler responded to
reports about the scandal by saying:
'Stories are being run based on hearsay,
innuendo, guilt by association.'
He also said 'No one in the White House at any time directed acts of sabotage'.
The first statement is just a
criticism of the press.
The second one is very carefully worded to be technically true: like, no one in, that is physically inside the White House,
directed, that is
directly oversaw, acts of sabotage.
President Nixon had still totally
committed obstruction of justice, of course,
but there was no direction of
acts of sabotage from inside the White House!
In the decade since, the non-denial
denial has become almost beautiful in
its linguistic sophistication. Like, after
the National Enquirer published reports
of 2008 Democratic presidential hopeful
John Edwards having a child outside of
his marriage he said: 'That's tabloid trash!
They're full of lies!'
But of course saying that tabloids are full of lies is not the same thing as saying that the tabloid is lying about that particular story.
He later said that his wife was beautiful and sexy, which again is not the same thing as saying he wasn't having an affair.
And then finally he
said 'The story's just false'.
'False' is a word you hear a lot in non-denial denials. It's useful because it's vague,
like maybe the story is false because
you didn't actually have a child with your mistress.
Maybe the story is false
because the story claimed you met your
mistress said noon, when in fact it was
12:06. Maybe the most famous example of a
non-denial denial came from Bill Clinton
who said: 'I did not have sexual relations
with that woman, Miss Lewinsky.' Now that seemed at first a total unambiguous denial but it turned out that
Bill Clinton was using 'sexual relations' to refer to a specific sexual act,
and to to, you know, like a sexual relations-ship
This strategy of narrowing the definition of guilt so much that you are no longer guilty is quite a popular one
Like when C.I.A. director John Brennan was asked if the C.I.A. was spying on Senate aides investigating the C.I.A.'s
interrogation techniques, he responded 'As far as the allegation of C.I.A. hacking in to Senate computers,
nothing could be further from the truth,'
because there was no password theft, it didn't meet Brennan's definition of 'hacking'.
But, you know, other than that, it was completely true, so it, really, it could have been further from the truth.
Because it was just that one step away from total truth.
There are many other kinds of non-denial denials: both Bill Clinton and Ronald Regan, for instance
used 'There's no evidence of that,' and 'I can't recall,'
You also often hear people not quite answer the question, like during the Bridgegate investigation,
New Jersey governer Chris Christie said 'I am not a bully!' in response to a question
that was not about whether he was a bully. And then there's the ancient tactic of criticising the press.
Like, allegations by the press might be called 'defamatory', or 'libellous', or 'slanderous',
or my personal favourite, 'outrageous'.
But, of course, lots of things that are outrageous also happen to be true
and words like 'defamatory' and 'libelous' are like 'false,' they're vague, they don't refute specific accusations.
I bring this up, Hank, because I think it's important to pay attention to the language of the people
who are, or wish to be, our leaders. Especially in an election season.
As voters, we need to be asking, 'When you tweet that something is false, or a lie, what exactly is false
or inaccurate about it? When you call someone a liar, to what lies are you referring?
And when you issue a denial,  what precisely are you denying, and are you in fact denying it?'
Language exists to facilitate communication, to make my thoughts transparent to you,
and yours transparent to me. But we have to remember that language is a tool that can also be used to render things opaque.
Hank, I hope you're having fun on tour, I will see you on Friday!